In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for September 15th, on which we commemorate, Saint Simeon
Archbishop of Thessalonica.
Our Holy Father Simeon was from Constantinople.
After completing his education in secular learning and divinity, he cultivated the virtues
of the angelic life, humility, meekness, self-control, and prayer, before succeeding Gabriel
who died in the year 1416, or 1418, on the Episcopal throne of Thessalonica.
In those difficult days, when the capital of Macedonia was about to pass under the Turkish
yoke, Simeon proved an incomparable shepherd.
In spite of poor health and frequent illness, he fed his flock unfailingly with the honey
of his words, renewing their courage in the difficulties that beset them, and exhorting
them to place all their hope in God.
He had great trials to endure from those who were tempted to surrender the city, either
to the Turks or the Venetians.
He expanded the little strength that illness left him, in preaching fidelity to the Orthodox
faith, and to the Emperor, and in exhorting the people to have confidence in the aid of
Saint Demetrios.
During the Venetian occupation, in the years 1423 through 1430, he encouraged the people
to bear with it, in order to delay the Turkish invasion for as long as possible.
Six months before the city fell to Murad II, on the 29th of March in the year 1430, St. Simeon
dreamt that he was in a richly decorated house, and heard a voice telling him not to
tarry there, admiring its beauties, but to get out quickly before it fell to the ground.
So he fell asleep in peace, spared the sad sight of the fall of his beloved city.
The inhabitants of Thessalonica, whatever their race or religion, whether Orthodox, Latins
or Jews, bewailed the loss of the father of them all, the good shepherd who had wholeheartedly
given his life for his sheep.
St. Simeon was one of the last disciples of St. Gregory Palamas, commemorated on the 14th
of November, firmly established upon the rock of the faith, he clearly set forth Orthodox
doctrine against every heresy, and illustrated it above all in his liturgical works.
He brought to the conduct of divine service in the Church of St. Sophia in Thessalonica a
splendor similar to that of the great church of Constantinople.
He composed many hymns and prayers, and compiled a vast spiritual commentary on all the rights
and ceremonies of the Byzantine Church, so that these treasures are not lost to us, even
though the Christian Empire is no more.
St. Simeon died more than 500 years ago, but it was not until the year 1981 that his veneration
received the formal recognition of the ecumenical Patriarchate.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.